estado de excepción en todo ecuador tras
la muerte de un niño de 11 años por un
fuego cruzado entre la policía y un
ladrón el problema de la inseguridad ha
pasado a ser una urgencia para el
ejecutivo de guillermo lasso todos los
sectores sociales y políticos debemos
trabajar en absoluta unidad porque en
las calles del ecuador hay un solo
enemigo el
narcotráfico más del 70% de las muertes
violentas que hoy ocurren en la
provincia del guayas está de alguna
forma relacionada con el tráfico de
drogas con esta medida de urgencia
aplicada en todo el país se espera que
la policía y el ejército tengan más
libertad de acción para controlar el
repunte del crimen organizado además el
gobierno prometió blindar a las fuerzas
de la seguridad con indultos y respaldo
absoluto de su parte ante eventuales
acusaciones injustas algo que ha
preocupado a las organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos ya la
defensoría del pueblo
este gobierno
indultará a todos aquellos que hayan
sido
injustamente condenados por haber
cumplido con su labor el ejecutivo
enviará en los próximos días un nuevo
proyecto de ley
dedicado exclusivamente
a respaldar a nuestros agentes del orden
este estado de excepción converge con el
aplicado hace tres semanas en las
cárceles de ecuador tras el motín
carcelario más violento del país que
dejó al menos 118 muertos y decenas de
familias afectadas en guayaquil
actualmente la presidencia de guillermo
lasso enfrenta un cúmulo de adversidades
con su implicación en los pandora papers
y la disputa con la asamblea nacional
para que se aprueben sus reformas
económicas de corte neoliberal